director wants to see a rollover are you
okay with that
remember if you don't feel good just
abort the shot there's no shame in that
all right I think in the original script
don't worry it's done there's no pain
it's over he came behind me with a
garretting wire and choked me and one
one night I had this dream but you know
where the handshake came from the
handshake came from showing you have no
weapon we may not know each other but I
show you we have no weapon and out of
that came the clasp to say I don't have
a weapon either I said what if I see him
in my garage and we're like oh and I'm
not quite sure but he's talking very
casually and he holds out his hand and
I'm like oh maybe he's going to let me
go and that handshake and as soon as I
touch his hand he turns my wrist with
his other hand comes out a knife and he
slices my arm and immediately he starts
to put Me At Ease comfort me it's gonna
be okay it's gonna be okay and I pitched
that and Nicholas is going that's in the
movie
we're gonna do that